MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
AMY UNRUH: Hey, everyone.
And welcome to another App
Engine Office Hours.
So I'm Amy, and with
me is Danny.
We're both App Engine
developer relations.
And what we're going to talk
about today is using Appstats
to optimize your app,
make it ran faster,
make it run more cheaply.
And so we're using some
materials that were prepared
by Proppy, who many of you
might be familiar with,
another App Engine dev rel.
So all credit to him
for these slides.
And so what we're going to do
is we're going to go through
the slides first and give little
demos as we go along.
And incidentally, we're trying
an experiment where I'm mostly
controlling the slides in one
location, in Sydney, Australia.
And Danny is doing a bit of
controlling of the slides in
another location.
So you may see me sort of roll
my eyes to the side as I'm
going through these slides as
we try to coordinate them.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to go through the
slides first.
And then we'll go to the
moderator queue.
And we're not able to invite
people to join live this time,
and so what we're going to
do for next time is start
gathering a Google+ circle of
people that want to be invited
to these Hangouts, which
will make it
a little more organized.
So watch for posts about that
both on Google+ and on the App
Engine group.
And we'll start gathering a list
of interested people so
that it's really smooth to
invite you next time.
So this time we're just going
to communicate with you
through the moderator queue.
Sorry about that.
So go to the GDL event page
where you found this, and you
should see the link to moderator
queue there.
And add your questions there.
OK.
So let's get started
with the demo.
And first, I'm going to give
just a little bit of an
introduction about Appstats.
So most of you are
probably familiar
with Appstats already.
And just in case you're not, let
me just give a little plug
as to how useful it is.
It's available for both
Python and Java.
And it essentially lets you see
a bunch of things about
how your app is running.
It lets you see where you're
waiting for network calls.
Figure out what RPC calls are
costing you the most.
Maybe notice where you're making
repeated RPC calls,
say, to the data store
rather than when you
should be doing caching.
All sorts of useful things.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to use Appstats to
show some what you might call
design patterns and
anti-patterns , which--
ways to design your app and
not so good ways to design
your app that really make a
difference with efficiency.
And we'll be able to see
this with Appstats.
OK.
So this is all covered
in the documentation.
But just a little quick overview
of how to set up
Appstats for those who aren't
familiar with it.
You first have to set up a
so-called event recorder and
App Engine config.
And then, also in App Engine
config, you can set some
configuration variables that
impact what gets tracked.
And so in particular, one thing
we're going to do for
this broadcast is we're going
to play around a little with
Appstats CALC_RPC_COSTS.
So we're going to be setting
this in our config file.
And you can look at the sample
config file if you want to see
some of the options that
are available.
OK.
And then once you've done that,
you need to, essentially
in your app.yaml setup, you need
to tell your app where to
find Appstats.
And the easiest way to do
it is just the default.
Use this built-in specifier,
and if you do that, then
you'll find Appstats
under _ah/stats.
OK.
And then there is something
that's new to the recent App
Engine release, which
is really very cool.
Which is an Appstats shell.
So if you configure this, it
basically brings up a nice,
little interface where you can
run arbitrary Python code.
And so we're going to use
that during these
slides, during this demo.
And so it defaults to
false in production.
You don't really want
this on arbitrarily.
But we've turned it
on for this demo.
And the flag that's shown here
is how you turn it on.
So we put that, again, in
appengine_config.py.
OK.
And before we get started
with our patterns and
anti-patterns, I just wanted
to put in a brief plug for
something new.
Appstats Analytics.
It's in trusted tester
phase right now.
And what it is, it's something
that essentially builds on top
of Appstats.
And it's an interactive
visualization tool.
It lets you drill down
into all sorts
of data really nicely.
It's great.
And if you're interested, you
can sign up for it with the
link shown here.
And so these slides--
so you don't have to scramble
to write down the link--
these slides themselves are
linked to in the GDL events
page, as many of you have
probably already discovered.
So you can go find the slides
there and get the link.
And please do sign up.
It's really neat stuff.
OK.
So let's do a few
little demos.
And here's where Danny and I
have to try to coordinate.
DANNY HERMES: Here we go.
AMY UNRUH: So we'll
see how we go.
Are you ready, Danny?
DANNY HERMES: I am.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
One common mistake that people
make that sort of slows them
down sometimes is they do a
query to get an entity from
the datastore when they could
just be fetching directly by
the entity key.
And before I go further, I
should mention that for these
examples, we're using
NDB and Python.
And if you're a Python user,
I would really recommend
checking out NDB, which is
the more new of the--
DANNY HERMES: Datastore APIs.
AMY UNRUH: --datastore
APIs supported.
Sorry?
DANNY HERMES: I said
datastore APIs.
AMY UNRUH: Yes.
And it has a lot of nice
characteristics that the other
one doesn't, including things
like asynchronous puts,
transparent cache management,
really nice transaction
management, all sorts
of stuff.
So I really recommend
that you try it out
if you haven't already.
And Danny, please break
in at any time as I go
through these slides.
I can't actually see Danny.
You'll see me looking
over sideways.
I can't actually see him,
but I can hear him.
DANNY HERMES: I did want to
point out, this particular
model also does not use one of,
in my opinion, the best
features of NDB, sort
of its secret sauce.
It doesn't use memcache or the
local cache of the instance
handling the requests for
actually caching the data.
So you see those variables
on user, the attributes--
that is, _use_cache=false
and _use_memcache=false.
And that, by default, turns
off those two intermediate
caches and goes directly
to the datastore.
So this is really a slide about
the datastore itself.
So I just wanted to point
that out, Amy.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah, thanks.
That's an excellent point.
We turn those off just for demo
purposes so that we can
see the RPC calls.
Normally, you would not
want to do that.
So we should make
that very clear.
Normally, you would not want
to turn off the caching.
You would want to leverage it.
It works really well.
Yeah.
So thanks.
Very good point.
We're only doing that
for demo purposes.
OK.
So what we're doing
here is we're--
and I won't go through the code
in gory detail for each
slide, because that would
take too long.
But essentially the gist of what
we're doing here is we're
doing a query based on the
name field of the user.
OK.
So Danny, click the
Run button there.
DANNY HERMES: And
there we are.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
What we're seeing here
is the new shell.
And I won't go through the
pieces of it in detail for
each of our little examples.
But just sort of look
it over at first.
We're seeing a timeline.
And we're seeing how long
the RPC calls--
each call in the little code
snippet, and then the total.
We're seeing the grand total
of how long our little code
snippet took to run.
And we're seeing RPC stats.
So, Danny, I think you
might have to switch
to RPC Stats tab.
I'm not sure.
DANNY HERMES: Yep.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
OK.
Yeah.
And that I'm not seeing
on my slides.
But you can also see the cost,
the so-called cost, for each
RPC call that you did.
Which is new and which
is really cool.
And up at the top right,
you'll see a little
explanation of what
these costs mean.
And so, as everyone might
remember, there's this concept
of small datastore operations
versus more expensive reads
and writes.
And so we'll see that in these
two examples, this one
and the next one.
So here we did a datastore
query.
Sort of make a note of what
all of this cost.
All right.
So now, switching back to--
DANNY HERMES: So Amy, if you
can't see it, the query itself
cost 140 micro pennies,
and the put itself
cost 600 micro pennies.
And those consist of two reads
for the query and six writes
for the put.
AMY UNRUH: OK, thanks.
Yeah, I actually can't see it.
DANNY HERMES: So you want to
head back to the slides?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
All right.
No, I think we're having--
hold on just a second.
I think we're having a bit of
a fight between our two.
DANNY HERMES: Oh, yeah?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
Sorry, everyone.
We tried to do something fancy
here with remote slide
advancement.
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
So are we on--
DANNY HERMES: Slide 10.
Now we're on slide nine, now
we're on slide eight.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
Yeah, I think you'll need to
advance the slides, Danny.
Sorry.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
No problem.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
Hold on one second.
DANNY HERMES: Sure thing.
So what we're seeing here, the
answer to the anti-pattern
that we just saw.
Rather than actually explicitly
doing a query,
we're going to be able, as
Amy said, to look up
directly from the ID.
Since we set the ID when we
create the user object that
we're putting in the datastore,
we can actually go
ahead and use that ID and query
directly by that ID.
So Amy, do you want to take the
reins, or are you still
trying to figure stuff out?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
Just for Danny's benefit, I've
switched to a different
version that won't be tracking
with yours, so you can advance
the slides.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
OK.
The right way to do this, then,
is to do a get_by_id And
so if you have the key to your
entity, be sure to fetch by
that key and not by
doing a query.
And so this is both cheaper--
it's a smaller datastore
operation--
and it's faster, too.
So Danny, do you want to show
the results for that?
DANNY HERMES: Wow.
So we see here in the RPC stats,
instead of 140 and 600,
the cost of the get is 70.
And that's because we went from
two reads to one read.
And the cost of the put is
only 100 instead of 600.
And that's because we've already
put that ID before.
That's not anything special.
This is really an anti-pattern
about queries
and not about puts.
Is there anything else
you'd like to point
out about this, Amy?
AMY UNRUH: No.
That's a nice, straightforward
one.
Remember to always fetch by ID
if you have the ID and it
makes sense for your app.
DANNY HERMES: And so what's
happening under the covers,
before we move on, I just
want to point out.
If you call a get_by_id on the
actual data class that you've
defined-- so here,
user.get_by-id--
what that's doing is, under the
covers, it's explicitly
constructing a key.
And then it's just making
a query to the
datastore from that key.
So it's a nice class method
afforded by NDB models.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
So advancing to the next slide,
Danny, just sort of
explains why, essentially
recapping what we
were talking about.
Queries require more RPCs, and
they're more expensive.
All right.
So, anti-pattern number two.
And this is a good one that's
easy to forget to pay
attention to.
Don't use indexed properties
if you don't need to.
And so as most of you probably
know, one thing that makes the
datastore so fast and
scalable is the way
that it uses indexes.
And each time you create an
entity and save it or update
it, it requires some
index operations.
And the particular indexes that
need to be updated depend
essentially upon the types of
queries that you are making on
your data, which in turn
is specified in
an index.yaml file.
So the number of index writes
that you need to do for a
given entity can depend upon how
you're using that entity.
But it can be a significant
part of the expense of
creating or updating
an entity.
And so one big key to managing
this expense is you don't need
to index every field if you
don't need to query on it.
You might often have entities
with only a few fields needing
to be queried on, and a
lot of them just there
to persist the data.
OK.
So the default is to essentially
index everything.
And so here's an anti-pattern,
number two, where we're not
really paying attention
to our indexes.
And then, if we go to the next
slide, here we're showing the
same model.
But we're saying for the secret
field, indexed=false.
So we didn't do that before.
And so the default
was to index it.
If we say indexed=false,
then we're not
creating indexes for it.
It makes our writes cheaper.
And it makes them faster.
Sorry, Danny, I forgot
to do the demo of
the indexed one first.
So let's go back a previous
slide and show how
costly it is to--
DANNY HERMES: For the
anti-pattern?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah, to do a write
when we're indexing a field
that we don't need to.
DANNY HERMES: I'm not sure.
I'm getting some sort of--
the Chromebook doesn't
like it.
AMY UNRUH: Oh, no.
DANNY HERMES: This
is interesting.
I think there's an iframe that
it doesn't want to be iframed
or something.
Let me reload the deck.
Sorry, folks.
This Chromebook is not my
computer, but it is the one
I'm using right now.
What in the world?
How do you right-click
on a Chromebook?
There we go.
I don't know why it's
not loading.
This is unfortunate.
So it's like there's
an-- oh, OK.
There we go.
Let's try it again.
I don't know what's
happening, Amy.
It seems like--
let me just copy the code
and I'll run it.
AMY UNRUH: And the slides
are online.
So if we end up having some
technical difficulties here,
we can just page through the
patterns without trying to do
the demos if we need to.
And you guys can play with
that yourself as well.
DANNY HERMES: Yep.
All right.
Oh.
Same issue.
It's there.
It's just behind this thing.
AMY UNRUH: Essentially, each of
these slides, when we click
Run, what we're doing is we're
doing a post to the
Appstats Shell URL.
And so you guys will be able
to play with this yourself
with the given slide URL that's
in the GDL event.
DANNY HERMES: I think what just
happened there was that
the code was too big, and it
tried to grow the text area
beyond what the screen wanted.
So I just deleted it, because
Chrome lets me do that.
AMY UNRUH: Oh, OK.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
So breaking down what happened,
since we actually
had to create this index
property, we had to do nine
writes to the datastore So there
were puts that happened
at two different times.
And that's because we put
the object twice.
So let's run the other one.
Let's hope this one doesn't give
us this big white object.
OK.
Let me delete that again.
Sorry, folks.
OK.
And this one, there were only
three writes because we didn't
have to actually create
the indexes.
So there's that demo, after
a bit more effort than we
anticipated.
But that's the point
of a demo, right?
The demo gods hate everyone.
So, Amy, do have anything more
you want to say about
datastore pattern number
two before I move on?
AMY UNRUH: No, move to next
slide, where there's a sort of
a recap of that.
Essentially, as we were saying,
there's a lot more
going on for each indexed
property.
You have to do four writes
plus another one to
essentially create the indexes
for that field.
And so any time you do not
need a property indexed,
remember not to set
it to be indexed.
The default is that
it's indexed.
So unless you pay attention
to this, you
won't get the savings.
OK.
Let's move on to anti-pattern
number three.
And this is a neat one that
highlights something that's
relatively new in terms
of App Engine.
So don't query full entities
if you don't need to.
So you'll often have situations
where you don't
need to grab all the fields
of an entity that
you're querying for.
And so here's a situation where
we are grabbing the full
entity, first of all.
So we're just doing what you
might think of as sort of a
generic, vanilla query,
where we're
getting our user objects.
So, Danny, why don't you first
show the cost for that?
DANNY HERMES: OK.
Ah, wonderful.
It didn't break.
AMY UNRUH: Very good.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
So the stats themselves,
for the RPC.
We have two writes, which cost
200 micro pennies, and three
reads, for 210 micro pennies.
Is there anything else you
want to point out?
The timeline or any particular
order of those guys?
AMY UNRUH: No, nothing
in particular.
We'll get to ordering
in just a bit here.
Another neat feature of NDB.
OK.
So moving onto the pattern
number three, what you should
do instead, if you don't need
all of the fields in your
entity, is do a projection
query.
And we actually had a Hangout
the other day on projection
queries, as well.
They're pretty cool.
And so does the syntax
is different for
each datastore API.
So this slide is slightly
different.
The gist of it is the same.
The slide is showing
the NDB syntax.
And so we're doing a projection
on email.
So we're saying, for our
purposes of this query, we
just need to get back the email
field of each of our
objects, and not all
the other stuff.
And so the query, when entities
are returned, first
of all, they're cheaper.
They're small operations,
like keys-only
fetches in terms of cost.
And they're quicker as
well, typically.
DANNY HERMES: So you
want me to run it?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
DANNY HERMES: All righty.
So let's see it.
So our cost for the puts has--
that's sort of unimportant--
but the number of RPCs we
actually needed for run query.
So actually, the cost
didn't change.
Do you know why that is?
AMY UNRUH: No, I don't.
DANNY HERMES: So I guess it's
probably likely that it's not
the actual cost of the RPC
that changes, given it's
relatively the same
amount sent across
the wire as a protobuf.
But it's the amount of time
to actually get it sent.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
These entities are so small
that the amount of time
savings is probably
negligible.
The RPC operation should have
been cheaper, however.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
AMY UNRUH: Should have
been essentially a
small operation lost.
DANNY HERMES: Let's run
it again and see.
Yeah, we're seeing
the same thing.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah, so go to the
next slide, which talks about
why this is.
Essentially, projection
queries only fetch the
projected fields.
And they're small reads, as we
were just talking about.
So it'll be cheaper, and while
the time savings might mean
negligible for relatively small
entities, it can also be
a lot faster as well.
Now, one important thing to
mention, and with our
projection queries Hangout, we
did go into this in a little
more detail.
The indexing requirements for
projection queries are different.
I won't go into the details
here, but essentially you--
depending upon the nature
of your queries--
you might need to have more
indexes defined if you're
doing projection queries
than you would for
non-projection queries.
It depends on the nature of
what you're querying for.
So it is possible that if you
switched using projection
queries, your writes can be
more expensive if you're
needing to build more queries.
But your reads should
be cheaper.
So it's kind of a tradeoff that
you'll have to analyze.
And it's not necessarily given
that you'll need to define
additional indexes.
It sort depends upon what kind
of queries you were making
previously.
OK.
Anti-pattern number four.
Don't use an offset.
If you were looking at how to
page through your data, you
might have seen mention of query
cursors and offsets.
And offsets are, in a sense,
the simplest or most
straightforward model.
What you're saying is,
start giving me data
from a given point.
So for example, in the slide,
we're saying we want 10
entities, but we want starting
at offset 10.
So starting at entity number 10
in the list that would have
been returned.
And so this is often a really
straightforward way,
conceptually, to page
through your data.
Because you're saying,
I want to start here.
And I want to get some number
of entities from this point.
OK.
So, why don't you go ahead and
run that query, Danny,
DANNY HERMES: All righty.
AMY UNRUH: Turns out that this
can be the non-optimal way to
do it, for reasons we'll
talk about in a minute.
This might be another case where
it's relatively simple
and we don't see much
of a savings for
this particular example.
But we'll talk about why,
in general, it can be a
bad thing to do.
DANNY HERMES: So the
writes not so much
important to note here.
We see 80 writes.
But that's because we populated
20 entities called
Heidi zero through Heidi 19.
Or those were the
keys, excuse me.
But the reads are what we
want to take note of.
So we see here 32 reads.
And that's a result of, as we
see, first querying the first
10, and then, of course,
getting the second 10.
And we'll explain a bit of the
differences after we see the
actual pattern.
But 32, that's your
magic number.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
So let's look at what's
often the more
preferred way to do it.
And then we'll talk
about why that is.
Often, it makes more sense
to use a cursor.
And the way a cursor works is
when you do a query, you can
request back a cursor,
essentially a pointer to where
you were in the query.
And you can use that for
a substitute query.
You can say, start from this
point for my next query.
And you pass the cursor back
into the subsequent query.
So that's what we're
seeing here.
We're passing in the
start cursor.
So instead of using an offset,
saying start at entity 10, or
start at entity 100, or
whatever, we're getting a
cursor when we do the query.
And then we're passing it back
into the subsequent query.
So why don't you run
that one, Danny?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah,
let's see it.
So looking at the stats, instead
of 32 reads, we have
22 reads for queries and
one read for next.
And next is a read that
we haven't seen yet.
So this is actually unique
to cursors and paging.
But that is sort of the
gist of what we
want you to see here.
We went from 32 to 22 plus
1 extra next read.
So what are the implications,
Amy?
AMY UNRUH: OK.
So moving to the next slide.
So why is this?
Essentially, what's going on
is that when you use an
offset, you're still essentially
fetching the
results, even the first 10,
or first however many.
You're discarding them,
but you're still
needing to fetch them.
And so it's a lot
more expensive.
And that is amplified if your
offset is, say, 500 or 900 or
something like that, rather
than just 10.
So much better is to
just use a cursor.
And that doesn't require
additional results to be
fetched and then discarded.
You're essentially saying, I
know exactly where to pick up
where I left off.
Here's the point.
No extra fetching needs
to be done.
And so it's faster, cheaper,
less bandwidth.
And the datastore has
the concept of a
reverse cursor, as well.
I won't go into the details,
but essentially it makes it
possible to do pagination in
both directions using a
cursor, rather than needing
to use an offset.
DANNY HERMES: Yep.
Great feature.
I love it, actually.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
It's very nice.
DANNY HERMES: It's even helpful
if you have created a
bunch of entities and you want
to delete them all in a way
that's failover proof, you can
pass cursors from process to
process rather than actually
trying to do everything in
place, if you have enough.
But that's a talk
for another day.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
In general, it's a much,
much better thing to
do than to use offsets.
OK So anti-pattern
number five.
And now we're finally talking
about memcache.
Which you might have been
wondering where the role of
memcache was in all of
this optimization.
So essentially, don't do a fetch
from the datastore if it
makes sense to put your entities
in memcache and get
them from there.
And so here, I don't think we
need to run this again,
necessarily.
This is essentially what we
saw before, where we were
doing a direct fetch of
the entity by ID.
And so let's go to the next
slide, the pattern number
five, where what we're going to
do is fetch the object once
and then store it in memcache.
And we won't go into
the details of what
we're doing to do that.
In this case, we're essentially
dumping it as a
JSON string.
There's other ways you
could do it, as well.
And then later on, if we need
to fetch that object, the
first thing we do is check
if it's in memcache.
And only if we don't get a
memcache hit do we actually
fetch the object.
And so there are, as many of
you watching this probably
know, you're probably thinking,
well, that's a
little oversimplified.
And there's all sorts of things
that you have to pay
attention to when you're
using the cache.
And so happily, NDB actually
does, in fact, do a really
good job of managing
the cache for you.
So that if you use NDB,
you don't need to
write this code yourself.
You just need to use
the NDB cache.
So you would, in fact, not
set those use_cache and
use_memcache flags to
false, like this
example slide is doing.
And you would let memcache
manage it for you.
DANNY HERMES: Shall I run
it, or shall we move on?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah, why
don't you go ahead
and run it real quick?
DANNY HERMES: All right.
Let's see it.
So we actually have only
one datastore write
coming out of this.
Because the other calls, the
other RPCs, are memcache RPCs.
We have a memcache set from
the top and a memcache get
when we try to make that
retrieval instead of hitting
the datastore first.
So we just have one
write to get our
object into the datastore.
And we have no other
datastore RPCs.
AMY UNRUH: And as we were just
talking about, the same will
happen if you use memcache
and don't set
those flags to false.
I think maybe we'll skip showing
the demo of that,
since we're running a little
short on time.
But it's essentially the same.
And you wanted to
show it, Danny?
It's kind of neat how
NDB manages it.
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
We may not even see
it hit memcache.
OK.
We only see it set memcache.
We also see a call to delete
memcache because it's undoing
what the previous one did.
It's invalidating the cache.
But we never see memcache.get
because in this particular
slide, we're also using the
local cache on the instance.
So it never even needs to
read from memcache.
Because get_by_id will
automatically
read from the instance.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
And that's, in fact, something
particularly nice about the
NDB caching model.
It will use instance
memory where it
can, as well as memcache.
It's very nice.
And then the next slide just
sort of summarizes this.
Reading from memcache is
faster and cheaper.
And then instance memory, which
again NDB will manage
for you if you let it use its
defaults, is even faster.
And it's free.
And so finally, one more really
nice anti-pattern.
Don't do individual RPCs
when you have to.
OK, so first let's just run an
example where we are doing
individual RPCs.
And by that, we're doing
100 puts, each
one after the other.
DANNY HERMES: And it is
taking a long time.
So the emphasis here is not that
we're going to be hitting
the datastore any less.
It's really the amount
of time spent hitting
the datastore, right?
So we see this giant cascade.
Most of them are pretty quick,
on the order of 20
milliseconds.
But every once in a while, we
have some extra latency.
So we had a 139, a 172.
And then it kind of gets long,
as we go down this cascade.
We're even as bad as
483 at some time.
So our total time, our grand
total was 6,674 milliseconds.
So almost 7,000 milliseconds
to actually put all 100 of
these in succession.
And they're all blocking puts,
so we can't get to the next--
AMY UNRUH: Yeah, one
after the other.
DANNY HERMES: That's why
we saw that cascade.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
So you might be thinking, well,
do they really have to
put one after the
other like that?
And no, they do not.
And this is another thing that
NDB makes very easy.
So let's look at
the next slide.
How can you batch these?
And it's very straightforward.
You do a multi-put.
Sorry, put_multi is the actual
name of the call.
And it's really straightforward
to invoke.
We're just passing put_multi
a list of
all of our new entities.
OK.
So let's take a look
at what that does.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
Let's see if we see a
cascade still, or
something completely different.
So rather than 6,600
milliseconds, our grand total
time, 457 milliseconds.
So it's a complete turnaround.
And we do see an RPC total
of 2,019 milliseconds.
And that's a different
statistic.
and I'll let Amy talk about
the difference between RPC
total and grand total here.
But the big turnaround we want
you to see is 6,600 to 457 on
the grand total for the RPCs.
So Amy, back to you.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
So moving to the next slide.
Why is this happening?
So essentially, what put_multi
is doing is it's batching the
writes, and it's running them
in parallel, essentially.
And so it's a lot faster,
and the grand total
time is much reduced.
You're not blocking.
You're not doing the
RPCs individually,
and you're not blocking.
And you are still charged
for all of your
writes in the same way.
So you're not seeing
any reduction in
terms of those costs.
But it's a lot more efficient.
And you can use this technique
not only with datastore, but
memcache, task queue, full
text search API.
DANNY HERMES: So it's still
the same cost for your
datastore operations, but you
no longer have the cost of a
poor user experience, right?
AMY UNRUH: Right.
OK.
And one more, real quickly.
Yet another great
feature of NDB.
I'm probably sounding
a bit like a broken
record, but NDB is great.
If you have different RPC
calls, you don't have to
essentially do them all
synchronously and in sequence.
Let's skip running this one,
Danny, because we're running a
little short on time.
Move to the next slide.
How can you avoid running
them in sequence?
You can use something that we
don't have the time to go into
in detail here.
You can use the concept of
futures, where you're
essentially spawning off
all of your calls.
You're saying, go
do your stuff.
Don't block on waiting
for the result.
And then when you're ready to
use the result, at that point
you can say, all right, now I'm
going to wait until all
these calls are returned.
So what we're doing here
is we're starting
the first URL fetch.
And we don't need to wait for
it to return before we start
the second one.
We don't need to wait for either
of those to return
before we start the first one.
And there's an analog that I
don't believe we have a slide
for, for datastore operations
as well.
Which is a put_async,
which does
essentially the same thing.
So this is showing RPC calls
that don't access the
datastore, but there's a
put_async variant for
accessing the datastore
in the same way.
So the concept is basically,
start a bunch of operations
and then you can do some
stuff in between.
Then when you need them to have
all be done, then you can
synchronize and wait for
them all to finish.
And why do this?
Well, latency depends on the
slowest async RPC, so it's
good to do as much other
computation is you can while
you're waiting for
the I/O. All right.
Anything you wanted to add,
Danny, before we [INAUDIBLE]
and get a few questions?
DANNY HERMES: I did just want to
mention that using futures
is a great feature of NDB, but
URL Fetch also has fetch async
already within that API.
But you have to sort of write
your own wrappers around it,
and figure out your own
ways that you want to
wait on a lot of things.
Whereas if you use NDB futures,
it's just kind of
done for you.
AMY UNRUH: And applicable
to other things,
other than URL fetch.
DANNY HERMES: Oh, certainly.
Certainly.
Yes.
That's a special
feature there.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
So just kind of wrapping
up with this.
Then we'll have time for
a few questions from
the moderator queue.
There's a related recent Google
I/O talk that's linked
to in the slides called
Optimizing Your Google App
Engine App.
And it doesn't make the same
use as the Appstat
Shell as ours does.
It has a little bit of
a different focus.
But it covers a lot of these
same concepts and more.
Goes into some of them
in a lot more detail.
So I'd really recommend it
if you're interested in
this kind of thing.
And then other things that we
didn't have a chance to
mention include things like
making use of the task queue.
You don't have to do everything
synchronously with
your user facing requests.
You can offload a
lot of things.
You can take advantage of the
instant scheduler behavior to
essentially control things
related to how soon your
instances are--
basically, how many warm
instances you need, how long
you wait for an instance to be
available before you start up
another one--
all sorts of stuff that can have
an overall effect on your
application latency.
And so, again, that's a topic
for another Hangout.
DANNY HERMES: Yield thank you.
AMY UNRUH: And again, many
thanks to Proppy for creating
the original version
of these slides.
DANNY HERMES: So I'm going
to stop sharing the
screen for a bit.
And I'm going to get the
moderator queue pulled up.
Give me one second
before I do that.
Amy, if you already have it
pulled up or if you have a
question from it off the top of
your head, feel free to go
ahead and start answering.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
I do have it pulled up.
And let me just say, I think we
ran a little longer than we
meant to in the presentation.
Sorry about that.
So for those of you whose
questions we don't get to, we
will post responses in
the moderator queue.
So look for it there.
So let me start with an easy
one, or at least easy in terms
of how I know how
to answer it.
Will we ever be able to run
App Engine apps on our own
servers, sort of like a dev
app server meant for
production?
And so for that, I would
recommend you check out
something called AppScale,
which is quite
an interesting project--
and I'll post the link here
in the moderator queue--
which essentially does that.
And I've never tried
it myself.
But it's a really interesting
research project, essentially.
Really cool.
So AppScale.
All right.
Let's see.
And then there's a question
about calendar events, which
we will also answer in
the moderator queue.
The short answer is yeah,
there are ways
to find these events.
OK.
You want to pick one
to answer, Danny?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
Sure thing.
So there was--
let me find the exact
text of it.
Let's see.
This is a question
about testing.
So somebody is testing with
Testpad, and they're wondering
if there's a way to disable
some stubs.
Or how they can actually enable
a logged-in user.
So I'll just say if
somebody wants to
check out the actual--
I think it's
google.appengine.api.users module--
there's some functions in there
that actually allow you
to work with users, right?
And there's one there,
users.get_current_user.
And all the sourcing that does,
it actually tries to
read some variables.
And so in Python, you can get
them by calling OS.get_env or
trying to actually use the
OS.environ dictionary.
And they set various things.
Like user is admin is either
a zero or a one.
User ID is set to some number.
User email is set
to some value.
And so if you're testing,
you can actually set the
environment variables yourself
before you're
running those tests.
And so all these sort of App
Engine functionalities which
take advantage of identity are
then just going to go ahead
and use those environment
variables.
So you actually don't have
to worry about a stub.
You can just set the environment
variable.
It sounds like this particular
person is familiar with
certain things like datastore
subs and other things for
doing testing, but if you're
not, we certainly
welcome more questions.
Because testing is important.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
Let's answer one of the
Appstats-specific questions here.
Let's see.
There's one question.
When you use the batch APIs,
the batcher under the hood
spins up multiple RPCs.
From Jason.
While this performance
optimization is welcome, it
makes the Appstats visualization
very busy.
Yes, it does.
Any thought as to how you
might group RPCs better?
So I think that that is part
of what the new Appstats
Analytics, essentially layer on
top of Appstats, is trying
to address, at least
to some extent.
There are different ways to
drill down into your data.
And so if you're not already
a trusted tester for this,
please do sign up
and take a look.
And the Appstats Analytics are
at a stage where we're really
open to lots of feedback about
how it could be improved or
what you're seeing that
works or doesn't work.
And so we'd really,
really appreciate
the feedback on that.
It's sort of an attempt to get
at some of these issues.
OK.
So another question from Jason
that I'll answer briefly,
about the stack that we
saw in the cascade.
And he was asking about why they
were getting longer on
the requests as you were
getting further along.
And there are various
reasons for this.
Latency is never a guarantee.
You don't know where the actual
data center or any
other particular physical
location of the machine is.
But also, if you're hitting an
instance, and you're hitting
the same instance with more
and more requests, then
latency can increase because
there's less memory.
And I believe the application
we were running was
multi-threaded.
So as more requests hit
the same instance,
it gets spread thinner.
And it's not able to address
things as quickly.
Do you have any other remarks
about that, Amy?
AMY UNRUH: No.
DANNY HERMES: OK, cool.
Do we want--
AMY UNRUH: Let's answer the
question from Bryce.
It's got a number
of votes there.
Although I'm not sure if
I can answer to Bryce's
satisfaction, but we'll
give it a try.
Will the CPM USD number in
AppLogs eventually reflect the
cost reported by Appstats?
Is it relevant?
So my understanding, and Danny
can correct me if he knows
differently, is that
yes, it is relevant
and is intended to--
it reflects reality.
And it's based on underlying
calculations that are tied to
what the actual charges are.
And so the RPC costs reported
by Appstats, I believe, is a
subset of this.
So that's why they don't
exactly track.
But to get to my knowledge,
it is relevant and
intended to be accurate.
Danny, did you have
any further--?
DANNY HERMES: I can neither add
to that nor contradict it.
So good answer.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
We can follow up and post
more information.
But yeah, it should
be accurate.
OK.
Let's go to a question
from Gary.
And we're almost running
out of time.
Yes, we are.
So sorry, everyone.
Again, anything else we'll
post responses to in the
moderator queue.
And next time we'll hope to
invite more of you into the
circle so you can actually
chat with us directly.
OK, so one last question.
From Gary.
What's the best cost-effective,
scalable, et
cetera, design for a sensor
internet of thing kind of
application.
Some of the constraints are
real-time responses based on
time window of data.
Maybe using backends memory,
push queue, or channel.
And also map reducing
historical data.
Well, that's a very
broad-ranging question that
maybe I shouldn't have tackled
just as we were about to run
out of time.
DANNY HERMES: I'm not
entirely sure I
understand the scope even.
Though I do like that he wants
to use all these features.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah, I guess in
terms of making things really
scalable, some general pieces of
advice would be lots of use
of in-memory caches
and backends can
often be really effective.
Depending on what you're trying
to do, you get some big
backend instances running.
They can stay up for
a long time.
And they can hold a lot of
stuff in their cache.
And that can be a really low
latency and an effective way
to do things.
DANNY HERMES: And they can also
run computations much
longer than standard tasks.
AMY UNRUH: Right.
Yeah.
Backends can be really good with
long-running computations
and things where you have
some sensitivity in
terms of your latency.
And, of course, task queues are
really good for being able
to offload as much as you can.
Anything that doesn't require an
immediate response, if you
can offload it to
a task queue.
And again, those task queues
can run on backends if you
need them to.
That can be really effective,
as well.
And I'm sure Gary, who's from
Sydney, I think we'll have a
chance to talk about this
at some later point.
So I look forward to
chatting with you
more about this later.
And on that note, I think we had
probably better wrap up.
We're a few minutes late.
Sorry, everyone.
Yeah, so see you next time.
And again, we'll get more
of you actually in the
Hangout next time.
DANNY HERMES: All righty.
Thanks, everybody.
AMY UNRUH: Bye, everyone.